我们女人啊，
如果说生在一个条件比较好的环境啊，
或者说找了一个条件比较好的老公，
能挣钱的老公啊，
所有的女人啊，
你人生当中学会的第一课一定是花钱解决问题，
花钱解放自己，
花钱让买自己的时间经历，
我现在就是怀二胎了，
但是我现在不确定这个孩子要还是不要，
现在有点纠结，
所以说咱们现在是啥条件呀，
家里面条件挺好的，
就是我老公也挺能挣钱的，
养孩子是没太大问题，
但是就是我很纠结，
这个二胎生下来没人管，
因为一胎的时候孩子就是我管的，
我父母这边帮我，
然后我婆婆那边嘛，
他们管的少，
二胎的话，
我公婆边就是基本上是也不太愿意管，
我老公呢，
他就特别忙，
就只能靠着我，
我就有点纠结这个事情，
咱先说条件好到什么程度吧，
就家里资产加起来多少钱，
然后你们两口子的收入一个月加起来多少钱？
如果条件好到一定程度的话，
咱可以花钱请人管他年薪就是一年大概也能挣个100来个吧，
就是保守一点，
我这边就是一个小职员，
家里的资产呢，
有负债吗？
没有，
你说就是有一套房，
然后还有两个车，
那男方的态度是什么呢？
想要你生吗？
对于我老公是特别想要孩子，
想要二胎，
如果年入100多万的话。
啊，
没有人管，
咱可以请育儿嫂，
育儿嫂我不知道在你们当地的价格怎么样，
你们是一线城市呢还是几线城市，
我们也是个小城市，
小城市那育儿嫂可能也就6000块钱差不多吧，
那一年的育儿嫂的支出的话，
可能也就是8万块钱也可以啊，
那可以要啊，
因为毕竟第一没有负债，
一二房子也有了，
车子也有了，
第三年入100多万的家庭可以请得起育儿嫂了，
主要我老公她是有点不是很喜欢管孩子的人了，
然后她还有点妈宝，
就我挺累的，
因为一胎就是我一个人带过来的，
我们女人哦，
如果说生在一个条件比较好的环境啊，
或者说找了一个条件比较好的老公，
能挣钱的老公啊，
所有的女人啊，
你人生当中学会的第一课一定是花钱解决问题，
花钱解放自己，
花钱让买自己的时间精力，
真的，
不然的话，
没下这么好的条件，
白瞎这么好的命，
明白明白啊，
好，
拜拜啊，
因为龙飞姐我也是啊，
以前就是不舍得，
哎呀，
不舍得这不舍得那不舍得的啊，
你这不舍得那不舍得都得你自己干是不是？
我也是因为我穷惯了嘛，
你都知道我的出身太穷了啊，
所以让我来学会人生中的这一刻也很难，
但是我就想攻克这个点，
我就开始学会花钱解决问题，
花。
请人来给我打扫卫生啊，
做家务，
比如说我洗头，
我也是花钱在外面洗头，
搓澡花钱在外面搓澡，
我就花钱解决问题，
就给自己可以节约大量的时间精力来照顾好自己，
照顾好自己的情绪，
照顾好自己的皮肤，
照顾好自己的身体啊，
像他这个情况，
他确实有这个资格啊，
年入100多万的家庭，
没有负债，
没有房贷车贷，
没有负债的家庭，
他当然可以花钱解决问题了，
我们也不是说炫富的意思，
我就说如果姐妹你正好你有这个运气，
你找到一个条件比较好的，
家里面不差钱的，
你一定要学会花钱解决问题这个本事，
你才有可能越过越好，
是这么个意思啊，
记得点赞关注哦。